pas
[Musique]
ce matin sous les halles du marché de
dijon ne fait pas très chaud
il est encore tôt pour la majorité des
clients mais pas pour les artisans déjà
au travail
quentin est au boulot depuis un bon
moment le travail les horaires ça ne lui
a jamais fait peur
faut aimer le travail
pas de feignants
une bonne ambiance
bonne entente ils vont patron il a déjà
zappé de boucher et là il part sur un ca
paix de charcutier ouais il va bien
et si quentin va bien c'est qu'il a fait
le bon choix de formation quand il était
au collège
voilà madame merci sorti 3e n'était pas
le meilleur
j'avais pas ou m'orienter j'ai parlé
avec mon père l'huile est dans la
mécanique
donc il a essayé de les mettre là dedans
mais ça m'a pas plu et puis mon frère
alors qu'ils étaient dans l'alimentaire
aussi il m'a dit nettoie dans
l'alimentaire et du coup d'eau puis ça
s'appelle donc j'ai tenté tue c'est un
métier c'est un beau métier aujourd'hui
comme prévu on va faire la pâte
feuilletée
ensuite on va la diviser en deux en
faire un métier qui s'apprend aussi à
l'école ici ce qui plaît surtout aux
apprentis 7 se retrouver tous ensemble
l'enseignement y est un peu général
surtout pratique et l'ambiance plutôt
bon enfant attend d eilat utiliser les
masques
d'ailleurs main c'est un peu mais c'est
à face ont dépassé c'est sa technique
on le remercie beaucoup friand à douille
afrique
un enseignant pour apprendre les bases
du métier et toujours ce va-et-vient en
alternance avec un patron pour se
frotter à la vie professionnelle
lui aussi a été apprenti à l'époque ça
n'a pas été aussi facile d'abord en
termes d'idées reçues sur
l'apprentissage
à mon époque si vous voulez moi c'était
la risée canton quand on parler
d'apprentissage quand on était au
collège c'était vraiment voilà pour pour
les mauvais pour voilà pour voler des
gens qui travaillent pas qui travaillent
pas à l'école mais bon maintenant je
trouve que ça a changé
les jeunes reviennent de plus en plus en
apprentissage et je trouve que c'est
bien parce que c'était beau métier alors
m'offre des jeunes pour pour reprendre
nos outils pour poursuivre le métier
quoi il faut qu'on puisse partir en
retraite no 6 1 6 4
les apprentis dans ces métiers de bouche
charcutiers bouchers boulangers
pâtissiers sont parmi les plus nombreux
à l'école des métiers ils sont deux cent
soixante dix sept années dans la
boucherie il ya des débouchés et dans la
boulangerie la pain sur la planche et
c'est ce que nous verrons dans un
prochain épisode à suivre